dad but dad bots are in you know dad
bots are like the thing right now how
about people were [ __ ] body shaming
[ __ ] Jason Momoa
and I tweeted this I might if people are
fat shaming Jason Momoa the rest of us -
oh [ __ ] he's a great body uh yeah who is
fat shaming the Internet in pots no
Vennela the internet was Jason Momoa dad
bought no way yeah he looks so good
though you saying he did or doesn't he
does he still looks so he looks fine
there yeah yeah that yeah it's a real
dad bot well they're mad they're
actually they look like Aquaman on the
right yeah that's a piece that's a I
need to tell you the walk does it done
the walk the rock doesn't walk around
like that that's turning movie sets man
you don't see with a shirt off all the
time like you can't sustain that all the
time it still looks great
they look we killing me I'll die for
that body I told you when I met him I
was with Frank Grillo a long time ago
and I was just sitting there I said one
thing no but I was like I said it
Frankie there's about something I've
ever seen in my life is that is that the
coolest looking human being you've ever
seen at six before and I mean that when
he's a little thicker were ya hear you
dudes all right dude of 15 years ago
when nobody know you know my thing is
there how you gonna body shame this dude
Wow because they're mad he doesn't look
like this like it's Jim Moody but it's
the same thing who talked about that
the guy who played in 300 oh well our
driver rod Butler was saying how you
know I was such an iconic movie role for
him and then what 15 years later he
obviously doesn't look like the [ __ ]
Spartacus where the [ __ ] his name is
Leena yes Leonidas so he goes on these
dates and go in the room with a girl she
like what the [ __ ] dude figure 300 Mitch
that was a [ __ ] yeah I'm sorry you
know I don't know what's going on the
right there but I don't know what it is
but I know what the left is yeah but
it's so weird like that someone is right
you was shred City that's him getting
ready for 300 though yeah
can't stay 300 specially unless you're a
professional athlete why would you blow
up do blow up a little guy this tough
man father time Gus you know what dude
no you can't keep burning weight like
that you can't keep doing that it's not
easy how nice would it be if there's
just a pill that just burn everything
off all the time there is it's called
anavar do it god you're really cute dude
you're convincing me bro just get one
see I look like Don the riot the blood
look like on the left yes you look like
the guy on the left
dude come on all right all right wait
DME with an ax bar DME with an amazing
what you can change it what's crazy to
me is how many Brad Pitt's got the
[ __ ] [ __ ] going on in Troy come on
he's always good-looking though I can't
wait for that Hollywood movie so a
worker at a Dairy Queen and it'll be
fired because her manager made a mistake
her manager took a phone order where a
mom was getting a birthday cake for her
25 year old daughter who loves Moana
untie Roenick Lee the 25 year old loves
Moana the mom orders the cake over the
phone and the manager who's taking the
order thought she said marijuana honest
and so a the manager game I sit on my
little pony I know that's what the
manager okay though that was the exact
design that's a manager okayed and the
girl who's working there at that time
made the cake and the manager gave it to
the mom later on the mom brought it home
I guess she didn't look at it before she
left they opened it up the 25 year old
girl so I was like what the hell is this
and her mom was angry too and the girl
who made the cake ended up getting fired
the manager that's not fair
later on a different manager came out
and tried to get her her job back but
she didn't want to cases yo my mama got
me a Milani cake and these [ __ ]
thought she said marijuana cakes
funniest [ __ ] an honest mistake in
pretty good work - yeah you're good -
great that [ __ ] highs [ __ ] my little
pony god that's hilarious
but yet now that girl is out of a job
unfortunately
she should be she should get a [ __ ]
lady might be on the roids Oh Delia he's
Jack no he's not in the right but he's
[ __ ] Jonna what he's doing he's jazz
put some muscle he's really chris has a
big frame it's got a belly difference I
went I went we were in the hallway of it
hey Mike am I crazy you and I are the
same size and you guys were definitely
not going out I feel like we're the same
size you're 100 click on here it's about
180 no not that one makes me look right
there Chris weighs 190 oh wait do Keith
his upper buddies jazz his legs are
super skinny Bubba I don't care about
legs look at his shoulders yeah but look
at his legs as midsection he still fit
fairly thin in comparison to you he's
leaner well you got 60 pounds on Bubba
you think why not I don't think I know
he's jacked man yeah but giant so you
know he just got big man yeah looks good
in it though you know I'm saying
looks good Tommy
it's disgusting I I can't do this
anymore like pose I said that to him and
then he posted it and I was like hey I
was like every time I send something to
you your Christmas to post or see you
I'm like yeah I think you get posted
yeah but that's just an awful body plate
or no no I don't want to look alright
I'm just saying that Chris is Jack
though he looks good man he's doing that
he's doing that movie role yeah in
Albuquerque like my JT what one is the
one I tied I wrote where I take my
breath away
I like the boxing scroll up it's watch
my hand up this way no I don't want to
watch him box please don't my hands are
good please just scroll let me scroll up
to the very top of it oh did you see the
one I posted bubble where I was like
there in bed do you see that one yeah
that's funny man yeah what is that why
and see that one which one this one yeah
linetti
you Dobie yeah it's alright I mean he
looks hideous is another dude okay we
all do but that app people think it's uh
you know it's a Russian app I think
there's downloading our [ __ ] oh yeah
have you heard of this no yeah it's
incredible Bryan Callen did it but it
turned into a picture of a coffin
that's hilarious look at Whitney's
coming you look like every guy who deems
me I'm not Instagram look at that face
not he's creepy oh yeah
just father time gets everyone man of
all the times a [ __ ] as we know
what we look unbelievable where'd you
get that
I was with bas Rutten Frank Shamrock
our boy why don't always forget his name
Duane Ludwig nope Bruce you a spider
Bruce Lee a famous classic fighter Matt
Coleman famous pilot Mike Tyson 205
pound champ John Joe eat this [ __ ] out
of storage L Chuck without Jesus oh my
gosh
hold on you were with a lawsuit and
structural price camera Frank stomach
Pappy Van Winkle it was great why the
[ __ ] were you with all those guys - um I
was in a I was invited to a dinner and
they were just there and I know I saw I
saw possum so hard I bet well [ __ ] did
you buy her dinner
they're like how hard he's your dick the
entire dinner yeah I was maitre around
we played Red Rover Red Rover and then
did you see who had the worst the and
two fighters and well Boston Boston that
[ __ ] Boston by sharp
yeah they I have no zero CTU you don't
see any I mean they're just I don't
his boss amoral still doing the podcast
together I don't know I don't think so I
don't think some bosses great here love
pasta sauce is the best such a good guy
so sprang they're both great and Frank
manages
Maranello he's his maid oh wow okay
they're super close yeah good guy man
interesting you have to doing with those
guys
oh but that's where you drink Pappy of
anything yeah you know what it is we're
all the same age so when you got a bunch
of guys with the only thing in common
though they're well but but but but in a
way we have kids we're the same age
there's something about being the same
age with a bunch of men where you're now
you're not talking on society or
anything you're just talking about life
like you're talking about we have a
boss's kid is it just graduated from the
high school it's this is interesting
stuff to me because I'm trying to gauge
what they're going through what I want
to expect with my kids what we end up
doing is talking about our kids almost
always it's so well yeah I think
Frankie's got kids who are my kids age
roughly it's okay Chuck we're honest
cause that way one older boy who lives
in Denver and then two younger ones yeah
they're young and your kids right yeah
well they but no but again we're talking
about school and where they go it's an
it's so interesting when when you get to
a certain age where the fighting mate
it's nothing to talk about it anymore
cuz what else you talk about yeah yeah
yeah now Chuck's a great dude yeah great
guy yes
all them are good guys I haven't seen I
haven't heard from pasa forever I love
him been married to the same lady I
she's that loves him ya know Chuck she's
a doll she's beautiful mm-hmm how's her
name Heidi Heidi I thought Dwayne was
with you for some reason no I love
Dwayne Dwayne always comes to my shows
in Denver something to lighten up the
bleachers release Colombian man went
through an airport trying to smuggle
thirty four thousand dollars worth of
cocaine under his toupee
so he taped the cocaine to his head and
that he got to pay that was too big for
his head and try to walk through TSA
with it it's the worst wig of everything
yeah I mean when I gave it if he was at
hiding stuff idea take that off what are
you like a giant bird yes I saw it was
like huh there's something kind of off I
don't think this is just a bad toupee so
they ended up searching his like
touching his head
and they realized there's something
under and that's how he got caught he
looks real a good cook how dumb do you
have to be to put
you don't know that you look ridiculous
by the way toupees
every time I see an older man with a
toupee you know my mother with a serious
face cuz where I got losing my hair I
think she goes wear a wig what are you
doing home with your mom on that but not
like this you don't like that one looks
so bad but how stupid does this guy have
to be obviously really think is gonna
work out obviously he's ways risking 30
years for 30 but also looks like you're
hiding a giant amount of cocaine
underneath that toupee without even like
if you just showing a picture might be
always hiding something under this but
my brains extra big yeah that's all so
you could wore like long hair can white
hat like there's so many things hey
rooster head what the [ __ ] are you doing
God he likes so ridic is things aren't
going well for him it's hope that's
hilarious just on my head
hey nothing to see here see one on the
other side see here I just have a growth
I would have been like it's a mole okay
I leave me out the tumor it's over the
layers